عام اخرون كهذا
تقترب حرب اوكرانيا من ذكراها السنويه
الاولى
وذكرى يريدها الاوكرانيون ان تقترن بقمه
سلام يعرضون عقدها بواسطه الامميه
عندما تدخل الحرب عامها الثاني او يتوقع
ان تدخل عامها الثاني من اهداف وصفه
السلام هذه عدم السماح لروسيا بالتلاعب
بموضوع السلامه لانها تقول باستمرار انها
مستعده للمفاوضات وهذا ليس حقيقيا
اي صيغه سلام ستطرحها بلادها ربما كانت
صيغه نقاط العاشر التي كشف عنها الرئيس
وزيلانسكي في نوفمبر الماضي ومنها استعاده
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وانسحاب القوات
الروسيه واطلاق سراح جميع السجناء ومحاكمه
المسؤولين عن الحرب
تؤمنكيه في كما تقول باهميه الفعل
الدبلوماسي في انهاء كل الحروب لكنها
تتواعد في الوقت عينه بفعل كل ما وسعها
للفوز بالحرب في عام 2023
لذلك وغيره ربما لا يظهر الرؤوس كبيره
اهتمام بالمقترح الاوكراني بل رفضه
لا تتبعوا شروط الاخرين في التفاوض وان
مرجعيتها هي اهدافها الخاصه والمنطق
السليم هل يعني ذلك انا موسكو ترفض الحوار
من اساسه نقرا عكس ذلك تماما في تصريحات
كبار مسؤوليها بدءا بالرئيس نفسه قبل
يومين فقط
ان بلاده مستعده للتفاوض مع كل اطراف
الصراع الاوكراني بشان ما سماه حلولا
مقبوله للجميع لكن كيف هو الغرب كما اوضح
هم من يرفضون التفاوض
لاحقا اعتبر وزير الخارجيه سارجي لافروف
ان الغرب سيطر في نهايه المطاف للجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات اما بلاده فمستعده كما
قال لمناقشه ما وصفها بالقضايا
الاستراتيجيه الكبرى لكن بشرط ان تغير
واشنطن نهجها
للمتفاوضين اذن شروطهم التي جعلت الامم
المتحده ترهى نقابل التوسط بشان اوكرانيا
بموافقه
الاطرافكين بمبدا الحوار على اساس الامر
الواقع اي اعتبار المناطق التي سيطر عليها
في اوكرانيا منذ فبراير الماضي روسيه
على الجانب الاخر تطالب كيف بالانسحاب
الكامل للقوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كشرط مسبق للتفاوض يبدو امره
بالغه تعقيد ويبدو ان تبادل الرسائل
الرغبه في التفاوض لن يكفي وحداه لصناعه
السلام